okay this is just so funny it's sort of
like it's not even really adding insult
to injury it's adding injury to injury
the day after Trump was found liable for
sexual assault and defamation of e Gene
Carroll uh in order to pay her five
million dollars he went on his CNN Town
Hall
and he made more disparaging comments
about Eugene Carroll and many of us said
sounds like potentially more defamation
CNBC reports Trump faces a 10 million
dollar defamation Claim by E Gene
Carroll after his CNN Town Hall remarks
he might end up owing more money because
of that nonsense that he said about her
e Gene Carroll filed court papers
seeking very substantial monetary
damages of no less than 10 million
dollars from Trump in light of recent
scathing remarks he made about her at a
CNN Town Hall
Trump's comments occur today after that
jury awarded Carol 5 million in Damages
for being sexually abused and defamed by
Trump she said Trump raped her in the
mid 90s in addressing room of the
Bergdorf Goodman Department Store in
Manhattan
it is continuing it is continuing the
lawsuit says Trump's defamatory
statements post verdict show the depth
of his malice toward Carol since it is
hard to imagine defamatory conduct that
could possibly be more voted motivated
by hatred ill will or spite
uh they go on to say Trump falsely
stated that he did not sexually abuse
Carol that he has no idea who Carol was
and that Carol's now proven accusation
was fake and made up by a whack job
Trump also insulted Carol's character
downplayed his sexual abuse of her by
asking what kind of woman meets someone
and then within minutes plays
hanky-panky in a dressing room
um it's happening again
and you really without spending too much
time on this you really have to be a
very special kind of person you could
say delusional you could say narcissist
whatever to do a town hall the day after
you lose a defamation suit in court are
ordered to pay 5 million bucks and then
within 24 26 28 hours go on CNN and make
more of the exact kinds of defamatory
statements that you just lost a case
over so at this point will e Gene
Carroll be able to collect these
millions I don't actually know the
answer to that legal experts who have
weighed in say probably but it could
take a while
and now you may be adding even more on
to it is Trump doing this because he
genuinely thinks he's never going to pay
is it because he doesn't care about the
money which would be very much unlike
Trump or is he just confused about what
defamation even is let me know in the
comments I certainly have no idea one of
our sponsors is electric e-bikes I've
been watching e-bike reviews on YouTube
for a while because I've been thinking
of getting one and I continually come
across electric as the brand to go with
if your budget is between 800 and 1300
and I have to agree from experience I've
had my electric e-bike for a little
while now I've almost ditched my car and
regularly bike at this point for errands
and things around my neighborhood it's
awesome cardio because I'm still
pedaling I get there faster I can see
more I'm reducing my carbon footprint
the e-bike came to my doorstep fully
assembled it has a bright LCD screen
seven speed gearing five levels of pedal
assist a powerful battery that you can
take inside to charge it's also fully
foldable I can put it in the back of my
car electric has models for every
lifestyle and you can Finance for as
little as 73 bucks a month go to
electricebikes.com to learn more explore
all of the incredible e-bike models they
offer the link is down below